Can you refresh my memory on the fed mendazal or Joe Tippins protocol?
So I don't know
If anybody's ever heard of that. I mean sure some of you have heard of that
But Joe Tippins was a it's just a lay person not a doctor who was told who was told that he had a layman
There's something to live with lung cancer and then his
friend who was a veteran area or something told him to do fed mendazal. So fed mendazal is a dog and cat
Deworming medication can be purchased over the couture we have it in our store. It is
In powder form typically for a dog or cat because you'd sprinkle it on their food and then they would just eat it.
And it's a health and helps with the wormine. Now fed mendazal works in similar ways as Ivermectin.
So everybody's heard of Ivermectin. Ivermectin and mendazal are good for cancer.
Not because of their antiparasitic function, but because they work on different metabolic pathways.
It has been found that both been mendazal and Ivermectin help increase the P53 tumor suppressor genes.
So remember you have two or suppressor genes in every cell and they are meant to turn on if a cell becomes the cancer cell
meaning that if the cell has a damaged nucleus and goes into rapid replication then it's supposed to turn on the tumor suppressor system.
Now you have multiple different tumor suppressor genes. The P53 are probably the most researched tumor suppressor genes.
They were the first ones discovered. So there's more research on the P53 probably than anything.
There's certain things that can suppress our tumor suppressor system.
So when the tumor suppressor genes turn on they help to cause the cell to implode by stimulating what's called the intrinsic apoptotic pathway.
It's a certain mechanism that turns on. I actually have some videos on how that actually works.
The intrinsic apoptotic pathway is called apoptosis 101, 201, 201 or something like that. I have several videos on that.
But to show this up, the tumor suppressor genes are supposed to kick it and it causes the cell to die and then you never have a diagnosis of cancer.
The truth is this is happening all the time in all of us.
Even if you have a cancer diagnosis, maybe I'm breast cancer, well there's a good chance that you know cancer is starting in your liver totally separate.
Maybe you have had a cancer or in your colon or in your ovaries or in your whatever.
And it's something damage that cell starts to go to rapid replication. Your tumor suppressor genes kick in and P53 genes are one of those tumor suppressor genes.
Then it causes intrinsic apoptotic pathways to be stimulated. The cell line is destroyed and you never knew you had cancer.
So remember cancer in order to be diagnosed has to be well over three million cells large.
And usually by the time a cancer is diagnosed, it's tens of millions of cells large and then it's diagnosed as a cancer.
So this you know the saying that we all have cancer is true, but our body is doing adequate job of keeping it in a bay so it never gets to the point of being diagnosed.
You might say well I love this call because I have been diagnosed with cancer so my tumor suppressor gene must stink or something like that.
Not necessarily your tumor suppressor gene might be doing a wonderful job of keeping all sorts of cancers at bay, but in the instance of the particular cancer you have.
So let's use an example of I have breast cancer right now. Well, when did it start? Well, I was diagnosed last May pretend.
Okay, well, when did it start? Well, it probably started several years before that.
One cell large to begin with and then some damage to the nucleus and now it starts doubly tripling and maybe it's three million cells large in in nine months.
And then it's still you can't feel it in your breast and maybe a year later now you could palpate it.
You want to the doctor got to buy absolutely blah blah blah not diagnosed.
So how did that happen in the first place? Well, certainly your tumor suppressor gene deeded adequately function at that given time when that started in your breast at that given time.
And there could be all sorts of reasons why not there can be different things that can suppress your tumor suppressor genes.
So remember, tumor suppressor genes, you want those functioning properly in order to kill a growing cancer.
What could suppress your tumor suppressor genes? Well, stress is one thing that could suppress your tumor suppressor genes.
If I'm under a lot of stress at that given time, that could be that could overwhelm my tumor suppressor system.
If I had a lot of cells damaged at the same time, let's say I received a dose of radiation from I don't know, I mean, I have no idea but pretend I had a, you know, okay, there, an example would be somebody who went under wet radiation therapy for a breast cancer.
And then they ended up with a melanoma on the skin. Well, it's because they had so much damage because of that radiation that it overwhelms their tumor suppressor gene
and the cancer started growing.
And this is why we tell you not to be taking a lot of methyl groups as a cancer patient because methyl groups, excess methyl groups and methyl cobalabated methyl folate can overwhelm, can, can silence tumor suppressor genes and can cause a cancer to start growing.
So there's lots of other things that could suppress your tumor suppressor system. You could have defects on your tumor suppressor genes. That's why we look at those when we look at your genetics.
So long story to say, well, how does that men is all the question was really asked about the protocol, but I kind of wanted to overview of how fed men is all that I've ever acted actually work.
They actually up regulate the tumor suppressor system. So when a person has cancer and if you could up regulate the tumor suppressor system, then you could effectively stimulate apoptosis from the inside out.
If you're stimulating the intrinsic apoptonic pathway in a cell and in stimulated cancer death, that's how curcumin works. That's why how burmer it works. That's how a lot of the natural therapies work for cancer as well.
There's multiple pathways on how they work and there's also multiple pathways, however, back to infant men is all work, but I find up regulation of the p53 pathway, most in three.
So back to the question, can you refresh my memory and the fed men is all chill tip into protocol. Now I'll put this up. We actually had a really nice mask Angie where it is. We had a really nice document that was a
infographic on the Joe Tippen's protocol, but again, the power is at B. We got a eight page letter from the FDA, wherever I talked about it a few years ago.
It was probably a year and a half ago where it like scared the ebgb's out of here that they're going to throw you in prison tomorrow.
If you don't take all the Joe Tippen's information and the fed men is all information off of our website. So we had to take all of that off of our website.
This is the things we struggle with on a fairly regular basis. This is why I tell people we cherish your prayers because the powers at B.
A. K. A the pharmaceutical industry that is controlling basically all of our government doesn't want these cures to be known.
So we had to take it off of our website and the whole internet was scrubbed of fed men is all slash dope Joe Tippen's information.
Now people have courage they put more stuff up there and we started to put stuff up there again, but just waiting for another letter from the FDA.
So anyhow, I have a nice infographic of what the Joe Tippen's protocol is typically it is the starting protocol for the fed men is all protocol is one packet, which is 222 milligrams of fed men is all, which is equivalent, which you'd give a 10 pound dog.
So it's not very much. It's a pretty low dose of fed men is also it's a one packet per day and you're only taking it three to four days per week.
So you can put it in your smoothie and it's really tasteless and then you're taking curcumin with it, burberry with it, vitamin E with it, which is our apop e and then typically you're taking CBD with it.
So I'll put that protocol up on the member site. Can anybody add the fed men is all protocol to their protocol or I've erected and I've erected I did put the protocol because somebody asked the question last week or the week before about that, I did put that either the dosage protocol up on the member site homepage for everybody.
Can anybody add those two things? Yes, the only thing that I ask that you do if you do add that is to get at least monthly a complete metabolic panel, which would be which would show liver markers.
Because we don't want it to whatever you're taking a medication, it can overwhelm your liver. Most people it doesn't, but it can and I don't want it to spike your ALT, AST and alkaline phosphatase.
So we want to keep an eye on those markers. If it's not doing anything to that, I've been on it for a month and I did my labs and it's there completely within normal limits, they were the same what they were three months before when I wasn't on this, then maybe you could spread it out to every two months, but we want to keep an eye on your liver markers to make sure that it's there's no issues with your liver.